Hi everyone.
Welcome to toxic Google today.
It is my pleasure to welcome
the lonely island for Popstar.
Thank you guys for being here.
Thank you for having us. Uh,
could you tell us a
little bit about the film?
Keith, why don't you just like tell
them a little bit about the film? Yeah,
you do it.
Okay.
It's a movie a, it's a musical movie. Yes.
Say mockumentary. Yes. So far. Uh, yeah.
All the pop you mentorees like, um,
Katy Perry. Pardon me? Or Bieber?
Never say never.
Classics one direction.
This is us going,
uh,
that's the John Written.
Do you want to get deeper?
It's up to you when you were looking
for an idea for a movie that we could do
our comedy songs inside
of and make feel natural.
So we were talking about maybe doing one
of those poppy mentorees as the genre.
Then a Kiva had a general meeting inside
term with Judd Apatow and Judd was
like,
I think it'd be really funny if you guys
did like one of those poppy mentorees
and he was like, I had the same idea.
We were just talking about that.
And Judd said, if you guys
write it, then I'll produce it.
So we started writing it two and a
half years later. The movie. Hey,
here we are.
Yes.
So
question real quick is every but does,
does anyone here work at Google?
Do you all work at this campus? Like
this building? Not everybody does. Nope.
Got It.
So Mountain View,
Boston present Beantown right.
Just kill.
That's the thing we say we say kill.
You guys can spread it around if you want.
No means to distribute information.
That's kind of a, it just means right on.
Essentially. I have a followup question.
Do you guys have any nicknames for Google?
Like do you call it like big
g or anything fun like that?
Papa goose.
Goose eggs.
Papa gigs. All right, good
to be here. Papa Roach. Yeah,
it's very slept better.
Alright.
Things we aspire to to
be like the approach.
And so how do you guys
feel about the Hooli thing?
Like do you feel like fuck those guys
or if you want to talk about like
mockumentary versus the most
accurate documentary there is.
Okay, fair enough. So
you think it's accurate?
I think it's pretty accurate there through
those guys at Pied Piper going to get
it together is what I want to know.
It's like they're right there on the
brink of greatness and that just can't get
out of their own way
anyway. Pop Stars. Great.
Yeah, that'll be on HBO eventually. Maybe
I'm speaking of Pop star
in terms of the process,
so how did you guys sort of find a
balance between writing the songs and the
plot?
Like
which was it a chicken
and the egg scenario or,
I was a little bit of both.
We,
once we decided that this was the
kind of movie we were going to make,
we started writing songs and brainstorming
the script at the same time pretty
much.
Um,
so we had a lot of ideas for songs that
were kind of free of the story that we
just thought were dumb and funny and
then we'd sort of shoe horn them into the
plot. But then as we started writing
and, and the story started taking shape,
we would then pinpoint moments
where we were like, oh, this should,
there should be this kind of
a song for this character.
Or like we knew there was a montage
sequence that was going to be about two
characters getting to know each other
and maybe if they made a song together it
would make more sense there.
Stuff like that. So kind of both.
Um, did you that's true. Yeah.
Accurate. I'll just fact check.
They say something. I'll fact
check it. You could do, um,
when you guys were writing,
did you take a different approach to the
writing the songs in this as opposed to
when you're writing like as properly the
lonely island? Like musical style wise?
Uh,
little of both, but a lot. Yeah. Cause
it was more specifically in character,
but yeah,
he could be ignorant in different
ways then maybe we could as ourselves.
But I mean,
similar to say like the Dick in a box,
dude's like there's an untrustworthy
narrator thing happening where my
character, especially in the movie is a
bit of a dumb ass. Uh, so his perspective,
like he was saying was able to
be inappropriate because you,
you don't forgive him it, but you're
able to laugh at it because you're like,
well, they don't think
that the people writing it.
Don't think some of both though.
Like so like throw it on the ground.
You're obviously a character in the past.
And then I'm on a boat where ourselves
but not for any real reason through it on
the ground.
I'm not a big fan.
Thanks for fact checking and I was
like fact checker. Just got fact check.
I keep a neuroma.
How was it being both behind the camera
and in front of the camera on this one?
Uh, it's exhausting. Yeah,
we wore so many hats.
Uh, let's talk about it. Um, no,
it was a, it was great. We, we uh,
we've kind of developed all three of us,
a real style over the many,
many years of working together. So we kind
of have a, our shorthand is very short.
Um, and then we would just get to trade
off who gets to say action, you know,
like we'd be like, okay, your turn.
And then he'd be like action and then
I'd be like Roshambo for it. Yeah.
We did a lot of really took a lot
of hours out of the day. Yeah.
And people will be like, you
guys were, and we were like,
we're concentrating on something shut
up and then one to do and then action.
Yeah. So it was a mess. It was a mess.
It came out well. So they weren't,
um,
is is this going to be like a weird,
healthy way for you guys to sort of live
out a parallel universe where you get
to get angry at each other and creatively?
Uh, yes. Yeah, sure.
Yeah. Sure. Yes. Sure.
Seems like a healthy
expensive form of therapy.
It's really, it's the most
expensive therapy there, I
guess. Making a big movie.
Uh, yeah. [inaudible] has been
describing it as the characters are us.
If we were not self aware,
so there's any,
any roadblocks in their
path that are challenging,
they kind of make the wrong decision,
whereas we make the right decision.
All three of them. Always.
Always. Yeah. You heard
it here. Oh, always. Yeah.
Always.
Yeah. Fact checked. Consensus.
It's important or they're like guys on
the roof that don't do anything here.
Yeah.
That there saying
that's awesome.
Sweet.
You guys probably had your choice of
guest actors and musicians for the film.
Who were some of the people you were
most excited to have and was there anyone
who was unfortunately unavailable for it?
I was,
we were all pretty excited
that Nas a nas the rapper,
he used to be called not Nasty Nas.
Now he's just not as uh, as your Jones.
He only changed it like 18 years ago. So
I know, you know, for the heads out there.
Um, but uh, yeah, no, like we were,
we grew up listening to him and so that
was a really cool person to have on set
talking about us and how he was a
fan of us growing up. It was great.
And then a Mariah Carey was another person
that I was really excited to have in
the movie. It wasn't us. You want to be
was our characters. Hold on a second.
You can see what were, we were acting
in pretending, so he wasn't a fan of us.
It was hard.
No,
I felt like he was deep down a fan of
us as I'll go out and go in it anyway.
Um,
who are you guys excited to have on set?
Ringo. Ringo Starr was pretty
crazy. That was, that was cool.
He was in this group called the Beatles.
Yeah, they had a couple hits. Yeah,
they were pretty cool boy band
back in the day. Uh, yeah.
Lots of cool people asap.
Rocky Dj call it. Yeah.
I mean you guys are clearly ridiculously
like media savvy or you're just going
to say ridiculous.
Why don't you go jump off the roof?
I think you guys use like social media
and the use of the Internet in the film
really,
really well.
But was there ever a concern that like
things would become passe by the time the
film actually came out because of
the editing process for this film?
Like we were kind of adding
to it while we were editing,
so that kind of changed as we went.
Honestly. Like a lot more snapchat stuff
added kind of as we went. What would
have happened if like TMZ went down?
Oh, it had to make some cuts. Um,
would,
would it be fair to say that like a lot
of your notoriety and success is because
of the Internet and how are you,
you guys sort of were discovered
that would be fair? Yeah,
I think so.
We always say we were incredibly fortunate
that we got on SNL kind of right when
streaming became actually
possible for video.
Like forever we had a website and it was
a big deal that we had videos posted or
you know, you'd have to submit your
video to a site that would host it. Um,
and even when we were first
getting it going in La,
we would tell like agencies and producers
and stuff we were meeting with like,
oh we have a website.
And they were like, cool,
send us a VHS tape because
they just didn't exist yet.
So like basically youtube became a thing
right around the time that we got on
SNL and did lazy Sunday.
So it was very good timing for us
when, when lazy Sunday came
out. Like what, at what point
did you realize like it,
it was something special
and it sort of like,
I feel like it changed the way that
traditional TV produced for the Internet.
Like suddenly it was cool to have web
shorts and it was cool to have extra
content that isn't like
for broadcast necessarily.
Well, we sat down before we wrote it
and we were like, let's change the way
you were just that. We were like, people
don't say the word viral enough. Yeah.
That is one of the negative
connotation for so many years.
We'll meet with people and they're like,
we want you guys to make us a viral video
where blah, blah, blah. And we're like,
you can't predict if it's going to,
you can't just so extremely popular.
We'll make a video and then maybe people
will watch it and we'll follow up.
Question, uh, to this. Um, do
you guys still have the, it's,
it's that are like organic, but then
they made them for you like the vanilla,
it's it ice cream. Oh yeah. But they're
like the ones that they made for Google.
There are some fancy, it's,
it's like that for you guys,
the ones that they made just for Google
that they made for papa good anymore.
You know what I'm talking about.
Some employees that were here
so they don't do that anymore.
Now it's no discontinued. You can get them
through. Those are the Nasty Nas heads.
They still exist,
but not the ones that have the Google
logo and are made with different organic
ingredients and stuff. No, no.
It was a big deal for us because
we used to get, it's it at school,
but they had them at our junior high.
You could buy them in the cafeteria and
we were like, whoa. Special edition.
It's it. I know. I was excited to come
here for that, but yeah, whatever.
Now we're just excited to see you guys.
But at first it was the insets thing.
Do you can't have, it's, it's, this is
this acceptable second edit model as well.
That's great to know. Um, it's,
speaking of sort of, uh,
earlier in your career,
it's been almost 10 years
since hot rod came up. Um,
what were some of the lessons that you
learned from that film that you applied
going into this one?
Has it been 10?
I'm just kidding.
No, it's not fine. It'll be
next summer, next summer.
What were some of the lessons?
Uh, just believe in yourself.
Yeah. It was a lot of that if that,
if you find something funny that
eventually a lot of people will tell you,
they also find it funny.
Yeah.
We know there they are very
different films obviously.
Like there's a ton of music and
this one there's less, you know,
motorcycles crashing, uh,
as well. Um, but it's,
it's a totally different format. So,
um, but I dunno, I guess you just learn,
you learned something from everything
that you make from even a small Internet
video or whatever. So I
wouldn't, I don't know.
Each thing presents its own challenges.
Even like a good snap, you know,
we learned like I learned so
much from a ground staff. Yeah,
no, no. Um, what, what were some of the,
what were some of the perks
of doing a longer form thing?
Because you guys have done well,
you've both done features before.
You're on your stick, not take on
but like television 30 minutes.
I'm sure. Yeah. It's like a good
Sitcom. It's a really good sick huh.
Award winning maybe once.
Um,
uh, but yeah. So what were,
what were some of the sort
of the challenges of adapting
and what were some of
the perks? I assume like aside from maybe
a good part is that you get to play in
like at SNL we were just throwing them
together so much so quickly that, that we,
we would never get to even like
location scout or like plan ahead.
We would kind of go,
it needs to be at an office and then you
would just show up with the camera crew
and the actors and go, okay, I
guess this is our office and we'll,
and we would just kind of make it up on
the fly. And on a movie it was, you know,
you get to take things a lot slower,
location scout,
then you got to go back to location a
few times before you actually shoot and
build sets.
And I dunno,
by the time you're shooting it's actually
very calm because you have planned it.
Right? Yeah. One of
the huge advantages is,
is to have turnaround of
just like that you can't,
like you have to give the actors 12
hours and the crew 12 hours in bed so you
can at least go home and sleep.
Whereas that SNL,
we would routinely make things and have
an hour to sleep at before we started
editing something cause it was
going to be on there. So that,
that was a big advantage. It's getting
to sleep is a, is a huge difference.
Not just in film. Just
in life. Yeah. Yeah.
It's really important you guys and drink
water to talk about a life hack. Yeah.
They don't let you have water at SNL.
Yeah.
To save a buck or two somehow.
The rumors about Lorne Michaels or
true that, no, he seems nice. Um,
so these are, imitation is the
sincerest form of flattery. Um, have,
has there been anybody that you've sort
of parodied or taking inspiration from
that has turned around in revealed
themselves to be a big fan?
Oh, what a nice version of that
question. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I thought that was going to
go. It's like, here we go.
We got to talk about how much
we love Bieber again, uh,
which we do, uh, who so many,
uh, will nick cage for me,
it was a crazy one.
I was doing him on SNL lot on weekend
update and it basically came about that he
was enjoying the impression and liked how
like psychotic it was and got the joke
that it wasn't literally of him was just,
I found a weird
character and called it nic cage and he
came on and did it with me at updates.
So we did like twin nick Cage's,
which is what SNL does. Um,
and he was really, really nice. It
was fun. And right after we did it,
the crowd cheered really loud and we
sort of walked off the update desk stage
and he turned around and he was like,
pleasure doing business with
and then just disappeared into the
darkness. Didn't come to the party. I,
no one saw him again after that moment.
I was just like, what's he ever there?
I like picturing that he
like threw a smoke bomb down.
Yeah it was awesome.
I'm sure he's like hunting treasure or
he's out there doing something good.
Something compelling to watch.
It's very important. Yes.
So, okay. Well speaking
of encounters like that,
you guys have clearly proven yourselves
capable of entertaining yourselves at
press junkets.
What's been aside from the Jimmy Fallon
thing that's been some of your favorite
sort of,
um,
well we went to Miami and went to
the Latin billboard awards this year,
which was rad was a totally new,
the whole show isn't Spanish
and we speak Uhmm Poquito uh,
made for some awkward interview APP,
the whole red carpet.
And I presented and it was a,
it wasn't like us entertaining ourselves,
but that was certainly the coolest and
most different experience we had this
time doing press.
It was really fun.
What was it like sort of living out, cause
you know, you shot these huge concerts,
um,
what was it like sort of getting to live
out that pop star fantasy we got to is
fun, right? Fun. It's really fun.
Yeah, super drink preproduction.
Maroon five was nice enough to let
us go to one of their arena shows,
like a sold out arena show in like two
minutes before they would go on stage. Uh,
let us run up on stage and it was like
me and norm just with Mike's like,
it's like hi guys.
And we were like,
Andy's about to come out dressed
like this guy's name's Connor.
Someone literally booed when
they said that like already
they wanted him to be called Andy. I was
like so calm Conor. And he's like boom.
But uh, and then, uh,
we had cameras there and it was
kind of just almost a camera test.
But then a lot of the
footage we actually put in,
we just shot Andy and slow mo for like
two minutes just running around acting
like a superstar.
And it kind of gave us also like a true
image of what it should look like if
it's a full arena because it is.
And,
and the footage is like at the
trailers and stuff. And I don't know,
was that neat for you Andy, to run
out there and see what's super neat?
It was two minutes of pure heaven.
But, uh, there,
there are a lot of sort of absurd moments
within the film during the concerts
and like what,
what was sort of the level
of one upsmanship cause
some things that happened to
both your characters are, are, I don't,
I don't even know how to
describe comedically awful,
comedically awful.
That's the review the movie.
I was going to say like outrageous,
but I guess comedically awful. Um,
yeah. Uh, I think that we were,
we were pleasantly surprised when we
were screening the movie that a lot of,
some of the crazier jokes were
getting the reaction that we had.
Cause we obviously love sort of like
more over the top kind of bits and uh,
and so, uh, that was pleasantly
surprising. And there
are some things that, uh,
one,
one incident that you're referring to
that you're kindly not blowing the joke
for. Um, but yeah, it quite
outrageous and can't eat.
And Andy had to shave everything.
I shaved every inch of my body for this
part and it's like a kind of de Niro
Brando level of commitment,
I would say.
That's a fair comparison and if
you want to spread that around,
you can. Anybody could say that. It
doesn't matter who said it first,
whether it was like our camp or your camp
internet.
Nobody actually checks. Yeah, exactly.
That's just words. Just words.
Time to fact check for
while. But yeah, I don't,
don't highly recommend shaving
every part of your body. It's your,
your spouse doesn't like how it looks.
Where, were there ever any points where
you guys were just like, this is too much?
Or was it just sort of,
did you keep plussing all of it?
You just decided to editing?
Yeah, but no, like, no,
we didn't pull back at all really.
We back on one joke that is,
there's quite a few DVD
extras in this movie.
There's about an hour
and a half of extras.
It's maybe more than the actual movie, a
full feature of worth. That's April, May,
June. I'm going to ask this question just
because it's been in the news a bunch,
but, uh, there's, there's talk
of the junk in one of the shots.
I hope I'm not ruining this for everyone.
Oh,
that's what I thought you
were talking about earlier.
Yeah. That's why I brought up the
shares, a wardrobe malfunction,
seeing that she was referencing but
then there's also a limo scene with some
junk. Yeah. Junk. Is that,
well we are not going to say because
people have claimed that it's their junk.
Well we've heard that the got out that
it was Judd Apatow's and we're not really
like an [inaudible] should ask him and
ask him if he wants to kill with that.
It is a feeling he'll say yes.
But
to be fair though,
we do want to,
we should go on record saying that he
didn't want it to be nepotism or just
cause he's a producer.
He had been sending us the uh,
audition pictures or email for weeks
even before we had written the scene.
It was unclear. Yeah. Whether
or not it was like, yeah,
just be subject line would
just be like better lighting
might've just been a dick pics itch.
Yeah.
He just wanted us to see it in
different lighting, different scenarios,
um,
where you at different shirts and then
like what it would look like pressed on
glass, all kinds of things.
And uh, so he would,
he would just send us those and then he
said, just throw this in the mix, put it,
put it in, you know, take my name off it,
put it in with all the other picks you
guys are going to be looking through. I,
and he wanted to win the role naturally
based on talent and and you know,
not based on just cause he's a producer
and then he won the role he did. Yeah.
I think that shows a lot
of artistic integrity.
Exactly what on all of the great produce.
All of our parts on us especially. Yeah,
definitely on our part too.
Yeah. I'm glad it worked out. Um,
we'll take audience questions in a
minute if people want to line up. Um,
all right, so you guys are from the
bay, Hell's yells, correct? Yeah,
Berkeley about them.
Ooh.
If you could go back in time and tell
your Berkeley high sells when he's been
advice, what would it
be? Don't change a thing.
Don't change anything.
Your sense of humor at 12 we'll be your
sense of humor at Hecka old or like that
one time. Like you don't have
to take quite that many shrooms.
You're not going to go with it. It'll
still be fine without that extra few.
They'll kick in eventually. Yeah. It
just wait. Just wait. It's coming.
Stay the course.
Hi,
I'm Courtney.
It's actually my 21st birthday and this
is probably like the best present I
could.
Yeah.
Oh, happy birthday. Hey today. Oh
right. You know you can drink now.
Yes.
That's so wild.
Yes, though I told my parents
that I probably be more, uh,
it'd be more likely that I pass out from
meeting you guys then drinking today,
but okay.
Do both
a drink responsibly that can
out for Courtney tonight.
Who's designated driver.
You what's driving cars or four?
Come on. Oh yeah, you can just
Uber it. Yeah, just do that.
Google stuff. The Google cars
I love. Those are safe. Right.
Unless there's a red light
that was ones do it.
There are ones just drive all over
the place, right? Yeah. Keith,
well do you want to tell it?
I they,
I have the Tesla and it
will just run a red light.
It's only what's in front of it. So it's
not like, yeah, check out the signage.
No. And you're just texting
and doing whatever you want.
Cause it buries driving.
That's what I call it. But to be
fair, he's got a real lead foot.
Very has a bit of a lead foot.
Yeah. And he'll just go fuck.
He'll float through that soccer.
Anyway, sorry, what was your question?
No, I love you guys and I
love Brooklyn. I nine Andy,
I see one show that I always bug
people to watch. Awesome. Thank you.
So I was wondering when is the rest of
the only on in going to be on Brooklyn?
Nine nine. Ooh, hard question. There
was talk of your and being on last season,
but he was so busy with this
movie that it didn't work out.
But I'm sure in the future he will and
Kieve doesn't really ever want to act,
so he could now that I'm in this movie
Guy, yeah, I have caught the bug.
Okay.
He's constantly doing like vocal
exercises and like body movement stuff.
Yeah. Very into movement. Very end
of movement. But yeah. Hopefully.
And uh, uh, since you, uh, Jake was
kind of based on you in the beginning,
how do you think Jake is kind of different
from you since he's kind of become
his own person at this point?
Um, well he's, aside from that, he's
a cop and you know, I ain't no pig.
MMM.
I Dunno.
I mean he's got like dysfunctional family
stuff that he's working through and
he's much smarter than me as well. Um,
he talks faster, he talks way faster.
The main difference, he's kind of like
the Cumberbatch of the comedy world,
I guess. I mean, you have noticed that
you guys usually have the same haircut.
Yeah. Me and Jay actually when
you guys are shooting. Yeah.
Jake and I usually have the same haircut.
What are you doing for
your birthday tonight?
Um, I don't really know yet.
I'm mostly working here.
Right.
So you guys,
let's get a towel every years for
one second and some cake cover yours.
Is there a secret cake?
Is it made of? It's it.
Okay.
Thank you so much for answering
my question. Yeah, happy
birthday. Happy Birthday.
Um, first of all, thank you guys for lazy
Sunday. I, this is my personal opinion,
but I think youtube is what it is because
of that video. So thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Not on behalf of a
problem to root it out, but yeah. Um,
I've read that you guys
met in junior high or camp,
I'm not sure which one it is or
maybe both. Junior high for us.
Can you tell us your meat? Cute. Like
do you remember how you guys met?
Tell us some stories about
that. Well, yeah. Well,
me and Andy were like chatting up some
girls and then we saw your arm and he was
being bullied
and
yeah, you guys don't laugh. And we were
like a real thing. You're like, ladies,
hold on. Put It on ice for a second.
They were cool. They chilled. Yeah. Yeah.
And, and the sunglasses down we
went over. Yeah. We were like,
we got a problem here fellas. Yeah. Yeah.
Obviously they backed down and you'll
be like obvious Phyllis. Thank you.
Thanks guys. Where are you guys
going to get a Gig? You eat lunch.
Do you want to share a lunchables?
Yeah. And then we all had, uh, it's,
it's together.
So you should probably mention
we have been paid by its it to be
all right. We'll go with that. All
right. Thank you. Thank you. Hi Guys. Um,
thank you for the digital shorts.
They're brilliant. Thank you.
You've been on the sets of,
on the set of girls. Um,
does Lena Dunham ever
wearing your clothes?
Not In one of the scenes that I
like one of our longest scenes. Uh,
no, she was wearing just a
mesh top the whole time. Um,
and I was maybe more impressive seeing
her direct simultaneously and then act
and readjust your lines. I
like, so she's like rewriting,
directing and also being nude at the
same time. And you're just like this.
She's incredible. She's really
incredible. Thank you. Um, yeah,
but she'd worked close the
rest of the time though.
Hey guys. Thanks for being here. Um,
I'm also a big fan of the digital
shorts and I was hoping you could talk a
little about your writing process.
Like how do you go from, like,
we should write a song about being in
each other's moms to actually deciding
which ones to carry through.
Are there any you wish you'd done?
How do you go from like
idea to a full length video?
Any you wish you hadn't done right?
Right.
Yeah, most of them. Um,
well that one specifically it was
because it was mother's Day actually.
It was the mother's Day episode. Trying
to give a gift that kept on giving. Yeah.
Uh, it, it happens all kinds of ways.
I mean that was a rare case where it
was actually motivated by something. Um,
Dick in a box is the same.
It was the Christmas episode and then
specifically at SNL for those ones.
I mean we knew something had to be on
TV that Saturday and it would be Tuesday
and then a lot of times we'd stay and
we'd stay up all night and if we were
really lucky we would have come to it.
But a lot of times we wouldn't really
like and we'd stay up all night Wednesday
and we would then stay up all night
Thursday until basically challenging
ourselves to think of something better.
And sometimes like for
instance with mother lover,
the idea was cracked on Tuesday and we
kept trying to make it better and oh no
it gets on that what we do is settle
down the gold settled on that on Tuesday.
Yeah. The golden rule of
that. And that's the third.
The third one we had the idea Tuesday but
didn't trust it and kept trying to top
it until eventually.
And like on Wednesday night and
Timberland we gotta just kept saying like,
cause like you guys are great at it.
That's a great idea. Let's just do that.
And we're like, no, no, we gotta be
sure was like no too. It's funny.
Uh, yeah, but that's our basic product.
And then once you say like, okay,
that's the premise,
then we put the beat that we're going
to record on on a loop and we just sit
there with pads or on our computers and
write as many joke ideas as possible or
like little pieces of versus and like
read them to each other out loud and go
like help me finish this line.
I have the setup that I think is funny.
What's the punchline?
What rhymes with this? Um,
and sort of cobble it all together
together. Yeah. Then we kind of, yeah.
Then we do put it all together. Like,
Oh, who has the best first line? No,
actually your line would be good first
and then we should do this one of mine or,
yeah.
So we kind of group write it at that
point and it would just light a bunch of
candles and I just let the
harmony. Hello. All right,
well thank you. Thanks. Thank you, Margo.
Hi. Um, thanks again for being
here. I Love Brooklyn nine nine.
I also think,
yeah, also had, I think my
dad might be a captain Holt,
like long lost twin, but we can
chat about that later I guess. Yeah.
Um, I'm also wondering, um, really
my brother is wondering, uh,
when will there be a hot rod too?
1990 never when pigs fly.
I mean,
not like we'd be opposed to it,
but it's not like that made
a killing the box office.
Yeah.
Thanks for the question.
Yeah,
good answer.
Thanks for coming guys.
Could you tell us about how you were
able to stick together through your whole
career?
Particularly like through auditioning
for SNL now you got something to take all
three. Just the money, right? Whoa.
No, we're, I mean, we got
very lucky at that Bowman.
That's probably the closest we've ever
come to having it be that we would have
really been on different paths.
Was when we were getting considered by
SNL and they had met all three of us.
But then Andy auditioned
and then there was a moment,
basically it was about it like
fog stories today was like,
he was tired where we kind of knew he was
hired and we weren't sure if they were
going to say,
hey,
we have one writing position and
it can be one of the two of you.
There was no way for them to know we
turn in a writing packet but all three,
it was the three of us
together had written it.
They didn't know us well enough to be
like, oh we want that one or that one.
So it would have been kind of arbitrary.
So I think they knew they either had to
hire both of us or none of us. Um, yeah,
but that, I mean they didn't have to, and
then we had a little pact that was if,
if two guys got hired,
the second guy who was as a writer would
not take the job so that the two of us
could continue to what's it's the worst
would be for one guy to get left. Yeah.
So we made that pack,
but also we weren't going to like hold
Andy back if he got hired from going on
his own.
And you never did.
Hey guys,
I actually took the day off to
be an extra in the movie. Oh No.
Have you seen it? Did you make
your cut? Was that the forum?
That's what my question is.
Did I make the cut?
What was it at the forum stuff?
So it was it the Inglewood Auditorium.
So I was in the bin Ladin one.
So it was like this up against the stage.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I love kid contact. Oh yeah, no,
that's not him.
That was the second part to the question
is I know that we filmed like a lot of
songs. Did all of them make it into
the movie or is there going to be just,
yeah, your odds are better and you
guys go the movie to support her.
Really important. I'm expecting
my check in the mail too. Yeah.
Uh, no, not all. Not all this hot.
All the songs are in the movie,
but they are all on this soundtrack,
which is like chock full of extras.
Uh, kind of circling back
to the earlier question,
we wrote many, many, many songs.
Then we whittled them down. Yes.
I think we wrote like 40 songs,
let's say. Okay. Or maybe 50.
Even then we widdled it down to like our
favorite 25 and then we probably shot
15 of them. And then uh, those 15
well there's about 15 in the movie,
probably in one way or another. There's
been, the soundtrack has 25. There's a,
there's a song with a con that we shot
the whole thing and we loved and it just
didn't work.
Plot wise of that is not in the movie
or songs that it would be the strongest
songs that just couldn't
fit storywise yeah.
When it comes down to
cutting songs like that.
Do you guys tend to agree or is there
ever sort of like discord amongst our,
their tie breakers inside promotion
though? Third strong discussions. Yeah,
during discussions, but it generally it's
to do with what serves the story best.
Um, and there's something freeing about
knowing that there would be a soundtrack
where they would live so we wouldn't have
spent time on something that we really
liked and know that it would, it
wouldn't just disappear. Usually if,
if one of us has a problem with an idea,
there is something slightly flawed
about it and then like us all discussing
together and fixing whatever that problem
is, just makes it better at the end. So,
oh,
thanks.
Democracy rules you guys.
We'll take our last few
audience questions. Okay. Hi
Guys. Hi. Great to meet you.
And Goldie, uh, I've been a huge
fan of yours since. Awesome town,
which had the best song intro ever.
Any plans for awesome town,
the movie or the musical?
No, that's the other question again, which
is very nice to people. Like, by the way,
that song was completely ripped off
from fraggle rock. You're just like,
even though like clap,
clap, kind of thing. Uh,
but just changed enough so
we wouldn't get sued. Uh, no,
there's no immediate plans for rosin.
Towe are kind of,
banks are real lives are kind
of awesome town. Like, oh.
Uh Huh. Uh Huh. Fuck
you keep, that's fair.
Thanks for coming in today.
Aside from its,
it's are you guys excited about anything
else? Being back in the bay area
besides the warriors? I was
very, I was at the big one.
How was that game seven with my dad.
It was fucking awesome.
Uh, yeah, just coming home and
seeing our families and smelling,
smelling, smelling debt. Good air. We're,
we're uh, Gordo, Tuckeria guys, uh,
our nails in Berkeley. You're
talking about food, right?
Like other food that we like.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Um,
so are you guys ever attempted to,
uh, expand into other sort of mediums?
Because if you did a a Broadway play,
you could theoretically be the first
people to Igor because of a song about a
Dick in a box. That's true.
Is there a temptation there?
Well,
who should we get to do the Timberlake
part on Broadway because he'll never do
it.
Stamos Stamos
done great. We'll make the
call. We look forward to it.
Um,
I think my last question for you guys is
if you had to each bring one album with
you to a deserted lonely island,
what would it be?
Mm hmm.
Hmm.
It's so hard to say without
sounding like a dick. Uh, for me,
just like a sound effect CD,
just like goofy sound effects
just to make me giggle,
laugh part sounds and stuff and like
just city sounds or like, you know,
it'll be like, oh, that
sounded like a door slamming.
That's actually kinda probably smart.
You know what I mean?
Cause he'll probably have missed
the foundation. Yeah, there you go.
That's what I was trying to say.
Just maybe like blood on the tracks.
I don't know.
Something I probably Yoyo Ma,
just best of outcomes.
Just best of Yoyo Ma.
I like what I liked the hits,
you know, the one that he does,
just the ones that get me hyped.
So basically just the crouching tiger,
Sandra. I mean, that'd be one of them.
Which just the number ones.
Well, thank you guys so
much for joining us today.
Had started [inaudible] everyone to go.
Thanks guys
for fun.